so many people dislike or hate old people
now why is that
I have personally never found an old person/older person that I dislike
I think they are the sweetest nicest people ever
they have wisdom, smart
they're just wholesome and pure why
why are we disliking old people
why why do we call them boomers
Why are we so mean to them
I just went to the post office to send off a letter
I had the sweetest old man help me
who's so kind and so genuine
it just made my day he just had such a good attitude
so I don't know
just remember guys
They’re somebody's grandpa
somebody's grandma, mom, sister, brother
we all need to respect older people and stop calling them boomers
stop disliking them, they're just like you and I
except they might be cooler actually